tu regrettes ou pas non je regrette pas
du tout si c'est à refaire la même mais
je suis quelqu'un de très honnête mytho
maisonnette moi j'ai non mais c'est vrai
parce que il y a dans l'émission tu te
compares à l'arnaqueur de tinder c'est
quoi le plus gros mytho que tu aies fait
une meuf j'ai vraiment vas-y j'ai dit
j'ai déjà une meuf que j'étais fils
d'héritier et que mon arrière grand-père
avait donné à toute une génération qui
est maintenant la mienne beaucoup de
bien sur Dubaï mais que en fait je
faisais exprès de dire que j'avais pas
d'argent à certaines personnes parce que
j'étais multimillionnaire mais ça ça a
mis des mots à prendre forme
en fait que tous les stratagèmes je les
travaille c'est du boulot aller chercher
les voiles c'est aussi la preuve que
pour moi aujourd'hui j'ai confiance en
moi tu vois j'allais le savoir j'allais
bien la voir ta Clio